hello everyone welcome to another
episode of connecting the dots today on
the show we have april april thank you
so much for joining us how are you i'm
done all right yourself i'm doing great
i uh i'm so thrilled to have you on the
show i've been following your career for
a long time i think you're doing some of
the most interesting work in tech right
now and i'm really really excited to
talk about it um so for those of us who
aren't familiar oh no i have echo
so for those of us who are not familiar
with your your background and your
career
what are you doing for work right now
well give me one second i am picking up
everything you're saying sorry
plus like twice oh no yeah i have an
echo
one moment
i had the youtube open in the background
so it started playing again
you hear it well i had it for a minute
but it's it's off for me now
okay how did you turn yours off because
i can't even adjust my
um i just i had to mute the the youtube
channel like if you've got the youtube
open in the background somewhere
oh i'm still getting it
um let me check if there's anything i
can
i don't think there's anything that i
have on that would be going through to
you
see the chat's not getting an echo this
is the only screen i have open
uh
nope
hmm
this is interesting
okay it's only me
one second everyone i'm trying to get to
my audio settings to see
if there's anything weird happening in
there
and
did it just start when we went live
speak for me yeah can you hear me
i can
i turn
i turn down
there's two zooms on my computer that's
weird one says zoom it says zoom
meetings all right we're good to go so
re-say what it was that you said yes
okay sorry about that so
um
yeah the the question i had is is for
those of us who aren't familiar with
your career do you want to talk a little
bit about what you're doing right now in
your job yeah so right now i'm a senior
cloud advocate at microsoft with the
spatial computing technology team
and i work on
a majority of my job is creating content
to help new people learn about the mixed
reality space as well as some of the
different tools that we offer with
microsoft
and in addition to that engaging with
the developer community seeing what
people are building and just helping
people in general with getting started
yeah and mixed reality is is interesting
because i feel like so mixed reality is
is that kind of an umbrella term for
like virtual reality augmented reality
um kind of anything you would do with uh
with a either a device like a headset
like an oculus rift or even the stuff
that you would do on your phone with
like um like tabletop games where you
play with your camera and stuff is that
right yeah and it's it's a spectrum
that's how you can look at it so on one
side you have augmented reality and then
on the other end you have virtual
reality so
with augmented reality um you're able
the spectrum kind of like
depends where you're on the spectrum but
with augmented reality that's when
you're able to do things with um as you
mentioned your devices
while also more or less blending in the
real world
as
far as virtual reality on the other end
that's when like you're fully immersed
in a um
in a environment and you don't have that
access to the real world around you so
that's when you get more into your vr
headsets right um somewhere in the
middle is spatial computing and that's
the area that i work in and with spatial
you start getting into an area where
your holograms are going to be spatially
aware as well which is
really cool and something that i've been
working on lately so
i would say probably one of the most
coolest uh examples i've seen of that
is when i met the folks over at
magically
for the very first time i tried one of
their devices
there were these like little like
knights
that like appeared in the actual room
yeah and they were just like fighting
with each other and they actually knew
what was actually real in the actual
world so they would avoid actual objects
and they could like hop on top of stuff
and do things so it was pretty cool
that's more so the area that i typically
focus on but i do things within um vr as
well and um ar2 but yeah yeah so
what a what a fascinating space and i
feel like we've seen a couple things
like this uh like isn't the new mario
kart
kind of the the spatially aware um where
you you set up the the cart in your
living room and then you can like crash
into your coffee table and stuff
yeah i believe i've seen that i'm not
big on gaming like at all but
i believe i've i've seen that um
in videos but if that's the premise of
it then yeah that's essentially what it
is is um yeah making your hologram
spatially aware yeah that is whatever
yeah
it that feels so much like the future
and and that so that's something that to
me feels like
really unapproachable like i if i was
gonna try to do that i don't even know
where i would start and so
like
is this a space that you would recommend
for people to to get into and try
yeah i honestly would say give it a try
i've only been working in this space
since the summer of 2019 so i myself am
still pretty new to it and
as time has gone by since then until now
there are way more resources available
on the internet for how to get started
whether you're doing some of the um
some of the learning paths on unity
i'm a unity person so i can't speak to
working within unreal or um with web but
unity i know provides different
tutorials that you can take a look into
and then also with microsoft we do as
well so aside from our mixed reality
documentation and our uh journey paths
for folks who are getting started i have
a police car going by so sorry about
that
but um we have that to help you get
started and then um i also authored to
learn modules on microsoft learn that
are also available for getting started
and our mixed reality team has done the
same thing as well so
it depends on
you know where you land for learning but
i would highly highly suggest starting
with learning c sharp if anything
and then from there start learning uh
unity if that's your chosen platform and
or unreal and then from there start to
get into the concept of what mixed
reality is and dive a little deeper with
what you can do with that very cool and
and so do you see this as being like it
seems like we're seeing more and more of
this so do you see this as being a
growth area in tech where there's going
to be a lot of hiring and opportunity
yeah and it's actually an area that we
classify within my organization at
microsoft as emerging tech if you will
so
it's one of those things where within
recent years we've started seeing more
and more companies create products if
you will and tools and software around
it it's like that brand new it's in a
sense it's like that brand new thing but
it's also not brand new this technology
has been around for years it's just that
more so in recent years more folks are
starting to get involved with developing
in that space or even creating in that
space and so as more companies come out
with um with even more advanced
technology in that area you're going to
see
more folks uh start to
learn those skills and then you'll see
more jobs uh open up and hopefully in a
postcode world you'll see even more of
that opportunity to find different
companies to work with but it's
definitely an emerging technology at the
moment yeah and that's kind of exciting
too because you know one of the things
that that can feel a little daunting
especially for someone new in the
industry is it feels like there are a
whole lot of people looking for that
first shot and not a lot of jobs and so
so it sounds like there's an opportunity
here where companies are just starting
to adopt mixed reality so there's not
there aren't a lot of people who could
say that they are senior
spatial computing engineers right
nobody's been doing this for more than a
year or two
so
that's it what a great opportunity to
come in and be one of the first to yeah
you know to be an expert before experts
are really commonplace
yeah and there's a lot of opportunity
there and for the folks who
have been working in the space um you
know since the dawn of time they're all
they're also really good resources uh
for for learning and getting started
it's just that the number of folks who
have been doing it for years is
significantly smaller than the folks who
just started working in the space within
the past like five years or so yeah yeah
that is super exciting
um yeah and so so i think like
your your career is is fascinating to me
because you've managed to get to this
amazing job at one of the best known
companies in the world you're working
with this bleeding edge technology and
in you know doing these really
incredible groundbreaking things
and you you come from a non-traditional
background right like your your master's
degree is in in luxury fashion right yep
um so i would love to hear a little more
about that story
uh
what kind of how did you end up going
from
working in luxury fashion to to just
getting into tech at all
yeah so like
most folks in college um some of us have
to work
and so i took on a part-time job working
in the luxury
retail space because i figured i'm sorry
that was my phone because i figured that
if i am going to have to work now then i
might as well do it somewhere that i
like so yeah i started working in retail
but at that point i didn't have any
aspirations to work in fashion it was a
way for me to make money and get
discounts on clothes but as um retail
has this thing where it kind of like
sucks you in and you next thing you know
you wake up and you've been there for
like five years and that's what happened
to me because over time i started to
fall in love with it and i was working
in menswear as well as visual
merchandising
and as time went on and i finally
graduated from undergrad
i started to more so have a reality
check with my potential financial
prospects of working in that space and
how long it would realistically
realistically take to get where i wanted
to be
and the fact of the matter is that
either i wouldn't be making as much as i
would prefer
or it would take me just a very very
long time to get to um to get to that
level so i turned towards tech because i
also had a certificate in business
project management from undergrad
and at the time i only thought of
project management from a business
perspective but when i was doing my job
search everyone was asking for it
experience and i'm like my professors
never mentioned this at all
so
i
felt a little discouraged because i said
you know i'm not
technology illiterate but it's also not
something that i have on paper that i
can take to um you know a recruiter or
an employer and say look i understand
computer so
so um what i ended up doing was finding
an internship and when
i interviewed for that internship i made
sure to mention how everything i had did
in fashion
um
could be transferred over to the tech
industry so having transferrable skills
was definitely helpful
and then during that very first
interview for that internship with um
the woman who became my manager
i
had
made it very clear that i was also
looking for something permanent and that
this wasn't just like a six-month
internship and then i go back to like
living life i made it clear that you
know i want a career and
literally in i don't know
five months of being in that four or
five months of being in an internship i
got a full-time offer
and from there that's really where
things kicked off but i did have a stint
where i went back to fashion for a bit
and
i was also in the midst of completing my
master's degree in luxury fashion
management because i said uh i just want
to work in fashion now
reality hit
and
uh
the same thing came back around for me
whereas it was like oh that's his
financial parts not going to be the best
i took a massive pay cut when i left
tech and went back to fashion
and i got burnt out because i was
working
two jobs just to equate to the um income
i had from when i was working in tech
and it was literally this sort of
schedule i would wake up early in the
morning
go to um i worked at club monaco and did
visuals there go to club monaco do
visuals and then from there um i would
go to equinox because i managed the
retail store at equinox and i would
spend all day there and then um
sometimes from there depending on the
schedule i would go back to club monaco
and work um you know there until the
evening but it was always some sort of
like rotation and then plus i was doing
school so as you could imagine that um
is a lot became overwhelmed
i'm not the type that asked for
financial help so it took a lot of um a
lot of me to ask my parents at that time
to help out so they started helping out
but then i said okay i can't rely on
anyone to pay any of my bills so i came
back to tech
[Laughter]
and uh you know time went by
i had different roles in tech and you
know now today i'm here
with microsoft so
you know taking chances is one thing i'm
a big fan of i've taken way too many
chances but i feel like that's really a
way for you to learn that
you know which what isn't isn't going to
work out yeah
i mean it's so it's such a good point
and i think that's like
that willingness to to take risks and
and be willing to to throw yourself all
the way into something is it makes such
a big difference yeah
because you know if you only go halfway
in then you're you're hedged and you
can't like fully embrace something so i
i i love to see
when somebody's like i don't know if
this is going to work but i'm going to
try yeah and i like to tell folks i'm
like i know some folks they're um
they're hoping to transition into tech
like now and i'm like i've done it twice
so
yeah so if i can do it then i feel like
other people can also do it because i
didn't have a technical background so i
feel like others could also can also do
it as well
and you said something that i think is
so so critical that i'd love to dig into
a little bit more which is you you said
when you were having that interview one
of the things that you talked about was
your transferable skills how all the
things that you worked with in fashion
were going to transfer into a job in
tech yeah can you talk a little bit more
about what some of those skills were and
how they transferred
yeah so the internship that i um
received was in i.t project management
ironically because i had no i.t
experience but i had project management
experience so during that interview i
tied a lot of what i did as a visual
merchandiser
into managing a project because visual
merchandising for those who don't know
what that is it's um if you ever go into
stores or look at the store windows and
everything looks pretty and wonderful
and all the shirts are folded perfectly
and all the in-store displays are cool
and awesome that's what i did so you
don't just go right into it there's a
plan as well that's involved and so it
takes a lot of planning a lot of
execution and a lot of that relates to
project management so i tied in a lot of
that aspect and then i also tied in my
customer service skills as well which is
also a really big one because as a
project manager you're essentially the
face of the project and you interface a
lot with
customers whether or stakeholders if you
will whether they're internal or
external so being able to work with
various personalities being able to
speak with folks who are higher than you
in terms of the leadership skills if you
will
and just overall in general having
communication skills was really big so
um i feel like working in luxury fashion
was probably like the best way to get
that experience because everyone's
privileged so working with the luxury
audience is is um
is it's very uh niche i would say
and you you you really develop a way to
uh communicate with folks so bringing
those bringing those two areas of where
i worked
in was very very helpful with
translating that to how i could relate
that to working as a project manager
even in the tech space yeah yeah and i
think like it's so important to bring
those sorts of things up because that
what you talked about like how do you
talk to somebody who's in a position of
authority like that ability to manage up
is so important and it's so easy you
know for a lot of people i know who have
worked in retail or they worked in
restaurants you've developed that skill
when you deal with an irate customer
that's a valuable skill and if you just
brush that off it's going oh well i just
used to work in a restaurant
you're selling yourself so short yeah
yeah i mean like when people if you
think about it how many hopefully people
do is too often but like even at
restaurants how many times have you gone
in and just disliked something and
wanted to like tell
your your server like oh this was bad
can you take it back like yeah that
that's that's what we deal with for
those of us who work in retail in the
restaurant industry but
over time you are you find a way to
overcome those battles and i think it
really does build a tough skin but it
also
um builds up your communication skills
with people
absolutely i think that's such a such a
like
incredible thing to just focus on like
really really dig into what have you
done in your previous role that that
already prepared you for for what you're
about to do yeah exactly um so on that
on that like i feel like the dealing
with with
uh difficult people is is a is a pretty
like headline banner kind of thing but
one that i'd love to ask is like what's
a skill that crossed over uh because i
mean you've got you've got experience
from like you you're you have one degree
in public policy one degree in luxury
fashion what do you what would you say
is the the skill from a non-tech career
or
kind of experience that was most
surprising that's been really useful to
you in tech
i would say there's two actually um
because if you look at both degrees my
first degree that i got from my
bachelor's um
it was uh international business well no
no no global business and public policy
which is international business
so a lot of
the
um a lot of the knowledge that i
acquired as it relates to the business
um space and how you run a business that
is actually
very very huge um especially in the area
that i work in within cloud advocacy
because it's not just us creating videos
or writing tutorials you have to truly
understand the business needs and how
what everything that you're doing rolls
up into what the business goals are
so
i know with some folks it's a little
harder to grasp that when they are
starting within their first corporate
role even for something such as like
social media for example um you have to
adhere to a voice and branding and
guidelines when it's coming from like a
corporate account for example what
you're doing your personal life that's
that but when you're doing something um
in my case if i were to do something
like a microsoft channel i need to
ensure that i'm also in alignment with
how the company
presents itself so there's the business
side and then for the um luxury and
fashion management side that i have
we had a period of time in our program
where we had to end up learning like the
adobe creative suite and
branding as well so
even though i hated working in adobe
especially illustrator at that time
it was one of those things that was
really helpful nowadays also with
branding because i mean i can't tell you
like how many times i use um any of the
creative cloud
programs today literally before you and
i started chatting today i was in
premiere pro editing videos so a lot of
what i learned in that grad program i'm
doing today and then also from that
branding aspect it's helped me um
develop a way that i present myself
um to the world that also
prevent that prevents it also creates a
sort of
familiarity whenever you see something
that i create and it's like it it's like
you look you can look at it and say oh
yeah april did that um i think that's
also very very helpful um as you're also
in your job search as well because it
does create a sense of cohesion in uh
the way you present what you're doing
primarily if you're working in advocacy
um i would say or like as like developer
evangelism and things of that nature
but yeah between having business acumen
uh
and knowing how to use creative tools
and branding
were like the like i said three things
they're like the three things that um i
would say i didn't expect to bring over
into working in tech but they play a
really big role in what i do today
absolutely yeah i think that's the the
idea of being able to bring
a consistency to work i think is such a
you can always feel it when somebody has
a kind of a signature spin on the way
that they present to the world
and we don't always notice it we just
can we just kind of in our the back of
our heads we go oh yeah i recognize this
work yeah um and so being able to create
that field being able to create that
consistency
that's that's a superpower yeah it is it
truly is
and and like kind of on that note you
you're
kind of a polymath like in in the sense
that you so you've got this this career
tech uh career in tech where you're
you're working in mixed reality you're
kind of on on one bleeding edge there um
you are also like to look at your social
media you're doing so many things you
you make your own clothing you you do
photography you are writing books on
python like you've got so much material
in so many different directions
um
how do like i have two questions about
this but the first one is how
how do you approach learning so many
different things yeah
so
i have a stem from my childhood my
parents were the sort of parents that
let me
try and do whatever i want i didn't have
any constraints over any of the
activities that i wanted to try out i
think that's very
very very impactful as you get older at
least for me as i got older and that
carried over into my adulthood because i
had so much freedom when i was younger
and so now that i'm an adult
whenever anything seems cool that i want
to try out i carry that mentality of
okay how do i get started to try it and
you know not everything that i do i end
up falling in love with but i can at
least say i tried it so uh yeah for that
i often get asked that question i'm like
you can thank my parents for that
cool so and then the the second question
that i have is that you know i i think
there's a lot of times a sense of
pressure when you are on social media in
tech to
um you know you'll see people uh stick
to tech and i so i'm personally very
opposed to this but i i i love seeing
that you bring your whole self into into
your twitter profile and and so i'm
curious how do you think that that has
impacted your ability to grow in your
career yeah
so i will say to start off
to not be your whole self is exhausting
i don't know how people can have
multiple uh
internet versus real life personalities
uh i think it's not worth
doing that because it's tiring you know
can you imagine if you had to be two
people so um so for me i think it's very
important that i do present all my
interest in who i am because
when it is time to uh move into a
particular role for example assuming
let's say
that you know the team you work with
they've been familiar with your uh you
know your online content and your online
presence but then if you start your
first day at work and it's like who is
this because they're not the same person
right like that's a problem you know so
i feel that
for me to share
um what i do online for me to interact
with folks and engage with folks the way
i do online
when people do meet me in real life it's
like oh it's the same person and it's
that consistency across the board
because
i i again i don't have the time to
switch personalities uh depending on the
situation
but i will say it's also been very
helpful because it's also what
people who um i've worked with as
managers you know they expect and
anticipate and they like it
uh which is also really great as well
i'm not asked to you know tone this down
a little bit or you know we thought that
you know you would do it like this but
we're not really seeing that it's like
i've gotten hired in both of my roles at
microsoft because working in mixed
reality is my second role at microsoft i
got hired in both roles with the
expectancy to bring who i already was to
the space that i was working in so yeah
i would say it's definitely worked in my
favor that is i i think that's such an
important thing too because you know the
the fact that you got brought in
because of who you present online that's
a differentiator you know if we're
looking at five people with with an
identical resume
um
the thing that we're going to make a
decision on is is which person looks
like they're going to make a bigger
impact and if you can see the whole
person
then you can better assess that impact
and so
three people have edited themselves down
to just their tech chops and you know
one person is being an entire person i'm
immediately more
uh interested in talking to the person
who who isn't just going to argue with
me about whether or not we should use
you know semicolons or not
you're about
[Laughter]
um but yeah so i think i i like i i love
this so we've got a couple questions
coming in from the chat that i'd love to
ask uh
somebody has asked what kind of schedule
do you follow uh on like a day-to-day
or do you follow a schedule
um i am a highly
organized scheduled person because if
i don't have a schedule
things
are forgotten and i always say if it's
not on my calendar i don't know about it
um
i will like preface this and say i did
at one point in life try to not be so
scheduled and everything fell into
shambles so um i've definitely
re-adopted um organizing everything and
a typical day for me if we're talking
about super typical
um i wake up i sit on instagram and
twitter for about
let's say i wake up around like usually
six that's just my internal clock sit on
instagram and twitter until about 8 30 i
know that's bad
and then from there i get up shower it's
nine o'clock my day starts at nine i
don't prefer like i don't prefer and i
usually don't take meetings before nine
and um depending on what the day is
usually i'm working on content so some
days i'm writing tutorials uh this week
uh yesterday for example i even tweeted
that i was recording like 14 videos over
the span of the entire day so um you
know one day might just be all recording
videos another might be all focused on
editing videos like that's what i'm
working on today
and i
like to just really focus on one thing
um in one day of course sometimes i'll
need to uh
to do a little do multiple things in a
day and of course there's meetings as
well but i try to minimize when i'm
working on for work uh each day so that
way i'm not like switching gears every
so often and just in like you know this
eight hour work day yeah after that um
it also depends on the day it is since
i'm writing a second book now sometimes
i just focus on that but for the
weekends i don't do anything work
related i don't do anything tech related
unless it's like for my book of course
but
usually that's when i sew i do any sort
of crafting um
[Music]
prior to these times i would go out and
hang out around la
but uh that's really how my life is run
yeah yeah i can i mean i i love the
honesty of that answer of like you know
spending time on social media in the
morning i feel like a lot of people just
skip that part right and and i mean i'm
the same way you know i i wake up early
and then i the first thing i roll over
and i grab my phone and then i just look
at twitter
i'm there between that and youtube
videos because also i don't spend all
day during like the day on social media
i know some folks um you know it's a
comfort zone for them while they're
working but for me once that nine
o'clock hour hits in the morning
i might hop on twitter
for like a scrolling session of maybe
three tweets or to respond to any like
notifications and then i'm right off of
it so that little period that i have in
the morning of instagram twitter and uh
and youtube that's really the extent of
my like social media um engagement for
the day now that's that's probably i
find that if i'm disciplined i do the
same but when i'm not disciplined i'll
i'll like have it open in another tab
and it just tanks my productivity
because i every time i get even a little
bit bored i'm like maybe i'll just
scroll for a minute and then i get
nothing don't do it
um so another another question from uh
arjeets is
is a degree important for a job or is
skill enough to get a job in a big
company so i feel like we we
this is actually a great question
because did your degrees play a factor
in you getting your your microsoft job
even though they weren't
cs degrees
no
not at all um
but what i will say when people ask this
question is it highly depends on the
company that you're applying to because
there's no one answer for every single
company in tech that is something that i
would highly suggest you do as much
research um in as you possibly can
when you're in that applying uh phase
for a job now for my particular roles
that i've had at microsoft i'm not sure
100 sure if either my degrees were
evaluated however there was more so a
heavy and
a heavy emphasis
on my project management background
which was experience so i worked in the
project management space for
five six years before i came to
microsoft so um you know i definitely
had the experience
in that and then coming into cloud
advocacy um a lot of it was focused
around my
creating content um while creating
content abilities and then realistically
when i came into the um xr space
by that point only had six months of
working in anything mixed reality in my
own free time so it wasn't as though i
had you know massive big projects and
you know i've deployed this to this
platform and then i've had 80 million
people do it like no i didn't have any
of that and i also didn't have a degree
in it as well so a lot of it was
learning once i got hired but
you know when people are looking for um
for for potential hires
it comes down to what that role entails
and what the job description is so for
me working in uh advocacy
um it's it's that engagement with the
community can you build a community
can you um
engage a community but then there's also
that technical part too because the only
way i can talk to community is by
understanding the tech right so uh you
know coming into mr i mean i had a
python background but i didn't have a
c-sharp so um you know i had that drive
on my own for six months to learn
everything before coming into space and
by that point my now manager we had
already connected in real life um
as well as my skip manager who was his
manager so
since i'm very open about my learning
you know they always saw what i was
working on in learning so when it came
time to do this internal transition at
microsoft
there there was
essentially you know there was no need
to bring up this portfolio of projects
because they now have seen six months of
me actually doing stuff so they didn't
have to go you know find any of it
because it was just there
so
so what you're bringing up i think is is
such a like
a fantastically important point whether
you're doing it internally like you did
or externally like um you know we see we
see folks uh tweet about their learning
journeys the 100 days of code people on
free code cam sharing as they learn all
these different processes to to not only
try to learn something new but to share
what you're learning as you learn it and
you know as you just said that makes
such a big impact on your ability to get
that opportunity yeah
because i think something that that is
really important about your story of
getting into mixed reality is that you
you got there
without a degree
and without experience so what you got
that job on
was
proving your willingness to do the work
yeah and i feel like that is one of the
most valuable things
like you know i know you weren't going
in as a junior but for all the people
who are looking for their first role in
tech sorry give me one second someone
ring the doorbell oh
um just because i don't have to get up
one second let me check the ring sure
uh but for you know for everybody
watching here you know the the
if you don't have the opportunity to to
show a resume that has a bunch of work
on it if you if you don't have years of
experience to support your your lack of
a resume then you have the ability
instead to to demonstrate this work in
public to show this drive you're doing
the work you're showing up repeatedly
you're willing to make that effort and
that is a huge differentiator yeah it
does make a difference and i would say a
lot of what i've experienced
um definitely heavily ties to working in
uh evangelism if you will because it is
a very public role
you're you're very often in front of
people so
uh
it's something whereas
if that's the sort of area that you want
to work in there needs to be that social
aspect to it that ability to feel
comfortable speaking with folks and it's
not always speaking to like huge
audiences it can be really as small as
like a meet up or you know if you have a
if you have
any sort of like group that you know you
present to maybe like 20 people every so
often like it doesn't have to be some
massive audience that you have but it is
that comfort and ability to um to to put
yourself in front of folks and to help
share um knowledge with others because
for me
in the area that i work in like we don't
sell products um within cloud advocacy
sure but we do expose people to
technology and uh that's why for me uh
you know living out loud online and what
i was doing what i'm doing in tech it
really played a big role in uh me
getting to where i am now in cloud
advocacy mm-hmm yeah i think that's a
that's like a just a great
it's a great outlook
um
so i think one one other question that i
have is is to kind of turn around all of
your experience and let's talk to the
the people watching right now because i
think a lot of them are in the free code
camp program and and looking for that
first opportunity so we talked about
social media presence bring your whole
self be a full person we talked about
the learning in public show your work
um
what other tips would you have for
somebody who's looking for that first
opportunity how can they stand out if
there are a lot of people applying for
that same role
networking
networking is how i got my my very first
role at microsoft
i didn't cold apply
and i know for some folks
cold applying which cold applying is
when you apply to a position without any
sort of connection or referral to anyone
in that company
and i've done code for applying many
times in my um in the years i've worked
in tech but i've always found that
networking to be
the most beneficial and i've also found
it to be one of the
quicker
ways for me to find employment
but with networking it's a two-way
relationship you do have to understand
that and you also
should not be in a position just to use
someone because they work at xyz company
i would highly suggest developing some
sort of relationship with the person
first yeah and um and then from there i
would say
if it feels right and if you're
comfortable and if you're applying to
let's say a role with their company
at that point i think it's okay to to
reach out from a hey i want to apply to
this can you tell me more about working
with the company so on and so forth
usually mostly if you start the
conversation like that it'll probably
end in the person themselves asking do
you want a referral um if the
conversation doesn't quite go that way
after a continued conversation about the
company
feel free to ask i mean does it hurt to
ask but i also feel like that should not
be the very first thing you do upon
meeting someone is asking like hey can't
get me a job um at xyz company so
networking is great um and it doesn't it
isn't something that's also um
instant gratification either i've known
people that you know i've known for
years and
a um there there wasn't a need to
potentially ask for help on anything
career related until like years later
for example
so it's something where you really want
to foster that relationship don't just
forget about the person you know
after 10 minutes of having a
conversation with them at a conference
for example like continue there check in
on them
um chat without really anything but
having that relationship first before
having that
need to ask for something is super
crucial
and
networking also helps with you know
getting that resume on top of the other
resumes in the pile
as well um but also recognize that it's
not always a guarantee that you're going
to be hired you know i've um when i was
looking for my first role at microsoft i
interviewed with a couple other
companies and they were all
from networking opportunities which you
know i never applied to any company
either in that time it was more so i
connected with folks online
and um you know they were kind enough to
refer me for interview and i had
interviews and this was like pre where
i'm at now times like i didn't have like
the 22
k followers that i had now i was still
in like smaller numbers so it wasn't a
matter of being some like big known
person it was just connecting with the
right people and um
that's i think that's like a really
great way to bump up your resume um i
know that everyone's comfortable doing
that completely understand
so if that's the case i would say
anytime companies hold any type of um
events or workshops where you actually
have the chance to speak with people who
work at the companies that's a great
opportunity to learn more about what's
available and then hopefully um you know
get to know someone that way
and uh if
if communicating engaging with others
just 100 not your thing because you're
not comfortable doing that
i will say you you will definitely need
most likely a strong portfolio to help
you um really get noticed and even with
that
make sure whatever you're presenting
your portfolio is something that you
would feel comfort that you would feel
100 proud of if you had to present it to
like a ceo for example right it needs to
be something
that is uh it doesn't have to be 100
fully polished and deployed somewhere
that people are downloading it's great
if it is but it needs to be something
that's polished um and relatable uh even
to what the company does as well because
it then puts the hiring manager in that
mindset of okay they already don't work
in this particular area so that learning
curve would be super low so yeah let's
bring them in so hopefully that tackles
for the people who are super social and
then people who are not as
social
and i think like you know you you bring
up a lot of really really good points
here so so one that i uh just to to
repeat like networking is a long game
it's it's not something that you're
going to say oh i want a job next week
let me start networking today yes yeah
think of it more like building
friendships right like you're trying to
make connections to people not because
you want stuff from them right because
it's good to have friends and then yeah
having more friends means later there's
a decent chance you know somebody who
knows somebody who can get you that
intro and so it's not a transactional
thing it's it's making your life better
you're you're finding people who have
similar interests that you like talking
to
um and uh so peanut butter in the chat
has a great question
[Applause]
it's a great name
uh but they ask how are you connecting
with others online like especially now
given that we're in
covid times we're not getting the
opportunities where we could show up at
a conference or a meet-up and they're
kind of the casual coffee chats so
if you're shy if you're not super
comfortable just like blasting into
somebody's dms and being like hey i'm
jason
um
where where would you recommend going
like what are the strategies that you're
using to to meet people yeah so um
i will say i'm usually everywhere so i
don't want to give
like 100 that response but
um i can give that after after i talk
about for folks who aren't as social
first so i will i will help those people
out first
there are significantly smaller
communities that you can take part in
whether it's on discord for example um
there's slack and i will say most likely
regardless of the area in tech that you
work in or um
pursue to work in there's some small
community somewhere and one of these
chatting platforms that isn't
necessarily twitter that you can take
part in and
typically those are what i like to call
safe spaces for um the area of tech
where it's okay to ask questions it's
okay
to um to really bring that beginner
mentality there and then you start to
get more comfortable hopefully with
people so if you're not into like the
really big groups of um engagement folks
there's that which i find to be um you
know definitely helpful for for those
who who don't want to be in that
one-on-one conversation with someone it
really becomes um you know like a group
conversation at that point so it doesn't
it doesn't feel as awkward sliding into
someone dms and having this like
one-to-one conversation yeah so there's
that
um for for those though who you know who
do want to be everywhere i would say
for me because i do work in the xr space
alt space vr has been um a place where
i've met folks i've i've gone to both
large and small events in
alt space and
i would say
usually when i've gone to set events
it's probably because i did some talk of
some sort so i end up chatting with
people afterwards because they have
questions so there's that
but for the larger alt-space um you know
hangouts where i didn't do any sort of
presenting
um you know people people literally they
will come up and talk to you um as well
and it's one of those things where you
see a group of people talking just hover
over there
and see what's going on and you know say
stuff so that's another way i've got to
meet people
um
twitch has been another way as well when
i was streaming um because it's so
public anybody hops into the chat and
then you start getting used to seeing
the same people there
and then finally there's twitter um
whether it's a conversation that people
are having around tech or around
something like silly or something you
know that's a serious topic that's an
opportunity to start speaking with folks
and you can continue to start speaking
with people um
and even like uh like chloe for example
i mean i met her definitely before covet
but we met on twitter and like we're
best friends now so
it's it's there's opportunity in a lot
of social areas to meet folks whether
that's
um with large
online gatherings or even smaller and
intimate
yeah i i think some of the ones that
i've seen um are like discord there are
a lot of small community discords
popping up around different interest
groups and so if you know
i i personally i'm a big fan of of just
being part of conversations like on
twitter it's really low stakes to to
reply don't
spam replies but like if somebody says
something and it's something that you're
working on or that you're interested in
respond like we that that's why you know
we're on twitter twitter is not a
broadcast only medium it's a discussion
medium um but if you're worried about
twitter
there are discords that are much much
much smaller groups and a lot of them
operate with really strict uh codes of
conduct so that they are
they're not only like safe spaces in the
sense that everybody's talking about the
same things but there's safe spaces in
the sense that you will get bounced if
you're out of line yep you will
definitely be put out
and that's that is also really really
important because then you can go in and
know that you know nobody's going to
nobody's going to come down on you
nobody's going to go after you it's a
place where people who are interested in
things want to talk yeah even like um
just brought up one and i've been
slacking on being as active on there
just from life but even like dev2 for
example with that platform um
i'm a moderator on there and i've like
seen different like moderator chats and
like it's like a serious thing like you
just can't come on there and harass
people and you know be this big like
bully like that's just not allowed
so um i feel like it's it's definitely
more comfortable for folks who are
trying to find
um you know that place where they can
fit in and feel comfortable
absolutely yeah i think that is that is
absolutely fantastic and it kind of
plays into you know there's a follow-up
question from uh newcomb i hope i just
said your name right i'm sorry if i
didn't uh about um how to make a
reputation for yourself
and and so
what we've talked about with networking
there's a there seems to be a point in
in my experience at least where somebody
goes from being someone i've never heard
of
to being a name i've i've kind of heard
suddenly to being someone that i
recognize yeah
you know and and i think that like there
are some some really notable stories you
mentioned chloe chloe is a great example
of this where i feel like three years
ago i i don't know that i'd ever met or
heard of chloe and now yeah she's she's
doing these amazing things she was just
interviewing bill nye like i was there
too oh my god
what an amazing thing that was right
like yeah and and it's um and and all of
that
kind of
builds this reputation so
what do you where do you think that line
is and how do you move from from
networking to to building a reputation
so i will first start by saying be
mindful that there's two type of
reputations there's a good reputation
and a bad reputation
and
it is very easy i will say to build a
bad reputation depending on um just the
way things play out in um i'll say like
the online space for example
but
there's also the good reputation side of
it as well um
but to build i won't talk about how to
build a bad reputation because i won't
help anyone here but to build a good
reputation
um
a lot of it comes down
to
uh
what are you doing in the community you
know what are you doing in the tech
space
and
you know are you using your skills for
for social good for example um are you
are you able to or are you engaging in
topics that impact us like when i say us
i mean everyone who works in tech for
example
um are are you doing
things with your skill sets
that um are helping other people grow
for example and then like once you make
it in tech are you doing things to help
you know uplift others and bring others
along with you in that journey
so it's not like you must do this only
one thing and now you have reputation
for yourself it's i think a really a
combination of things but
um if if you come to notice the people
who have good reputations uh in this in
this industry
they're most likely folks who are
doing things to help others
realistically um
i mean i could probably give you a
laundry list of things that people are
doing
but it's really folks who are doing
things to help others along either in
their journey or
as i hate to say this phrase but making
the world a better place so
i mean i i'm fully on board with you for
that and i think like
a way that it differentiates in my head
is that you know networking is an active
activity you are participating in
networking i'm reaching out to you i'm
talking in a community reputation is
what happens when you're not there what
do people say when your name comes up in
conversation does your name come up in
conversation um and and i think that
that reputation gets built on
how people feel
when you are networking if i if i come
into a conversation and and i can manage
to do something that makes you feel
better
then later if my name comes up
you're going to remember that our our
interaction was good it was a positive
outcome and then you're going to say oh
i like them they they were helpful
um and if our interaction wasn't good
then the opposite happens yeah and
we're never going to get all good or all
bad like it's always going to be a blend
but we can always try to make sure that
we're trending toward better how can we
think about the way that an interaction
we're about to have is going to make the
people on the other end of that
conversation feel are we making people
feel
smart capable like they're going to get
somewhere or are we trying to make
ourselves feel smart and make them feel
small those are all going to influence
your reputation and
you know people talk about that you if
you are present in a community people
will talk about you when you're not
there and you want to make sure that
that's positive that yeah
and i would say even like especially
within the tech area because it's just
so many things happen
um
even folks who are
um you know controversial and things
that they share
um you know being controversial honestly
can have a negative or a positive
connotation and um you know it could be
statements expressed that are
controversial to one audience um but
they're things that they're statements
that help people in the long run or it
could be uh controversial things said
that are super negative which i'm sure a
lot of us see on twitter as well so um
you know i i say that because it doesn't
mean you have to be this bubbly
um you know happy-go-lucky percy person
24 7 for example um i don't even think
that's like a thing that is like
realistic or authentic or human
but uh you know you can you can speak up
um
as well uh on on on topics especially if
you feel very strong about something but
uh just also do keep in mind that
how it's perceived by people it's going
to vary um you'll have people who love
that you said certain things and you'll
have obsess a subset of people that's
just like oh no i don't like that they
said this blah blah blah blah so it
really goes
both ways um
but that also feeds into reputation as
well
yeah absolutely i think that's that's an
excellent point um so we're we're kind
of drawn to a close here so um
chat this is your last chance if you've
got any questions you want to throw in
in the meantime april is there anything
that you want to direct people to
uh any links any resources anywhere that
you want people to check out
yeah so earlier i mentioned microsoft
learn really truly great especially for
anyone that's interested in working
either you know at microsoft or with
microsoft um products and technology so
check that out at docs.microsoft.com
for
people who want to be able to contribute
and write content of any sort and do so
in a friendly space
dev.2 so dev2 is a really great uh place
to be i happen to know both of the
founders and they're delightful people
as well
and then one other thing let me grab it
from my bookcase
my book bite size python
for anyone that um is learning python or
have learned python or has
um
anyone in their life that wants to learn
python or even children that want to
learn python because even though it was
written for children um really anyone
has used it my book's a really great
resource you can find information about
that in two places either on twitter i
have it penned as a tweet on my profile
for voguing code and then also on my
website either
aprilspate.com
or vegancode.com
it redirects to that website to the same
place so on there i have a page fully
dedicated to my book and that's where
you can find links and then also if you
um are on twitter for example
click the link that's in my bio it'll
take you to a link tree that also takes
you to how to get by size python so you
got some options there
yeah um well april thank you so much
this has been such a pleasure of
conversation i i learned a ton i hope
that everybody watching has learned a
lot as well um
i i don't see any other questions coming
in so i think let's call this here
um
any parting words for everybody before
we wrap this up yeah
um
when you feel like you're just over it
and tired just keep going uh we all at
some point have that feeling um i also
don't think it's realistic for anyone to
have never felt defeated or have failed
at any point in their career and i can
give you a laundry list of times where
i've definitely failed just know that
it's human just know that you're also
not alone and also just remember no one
was born knowing how to program like we
all had to learn how to do it at some
point
one other thing i would say is to also
remember that you are on your own
timetable and no one else's i know it
can get very discouraging sometimes to
see
you know some folks say one day i'm
gonna learn this thing and then three
days later
um big news i work at so-and-so company
now doing this thing and it's just like
how did they get there so fast but you
know you don't know everything about
that person we all learn differently we
all learn at different speeds but don't
be discouraged by that um it's it really
comes down to your own self and who you
are so you keep going be happy for
people definitely at least but don't let
it discourage you just you know take
your time if you need to
i have
nothing to add to that that is a
beautiful ending so thank you all for
hanging out with us today uh make sure
you come back next friday we're going to
be talking to jordan jackson who's a vet
that trans uh transitioned into tech
it's going to be a great conversation if
you'd like to hang out and build some
code together
i learned something new in 90 minutes
twice a week on learn with jason you can
check that out on learnwithjason.dev
we will see you next time
take care